Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Unos 7 millones de personas en el mundo
mueren cada año de ataques al corazón,
y de enfermedades cardiovasculares,
que provocan ataques cardíacos y
accidentes cerebrovasculares.
Esta es la principal causa
de muerte en el mundo.
¿Qué causa un ataque al corazón?
Como todos los músculos,
el corazón necesita oxígeno,
y durante un ataque al corazón,
no puede obtener suficiente.
Los depósitos de grasa o placas,
se desarrollar en las paredes
de las arterias coronarias.
Esos son los vasos que suministran
sangre oxigenada al corazón.
Estas placas crecen
a medida que envejecemos,
a veces se engordan,
se endurecen,
o inflaman.
Finalmente, las placas se pueden
convertir en bloqueos.
Si una de las placas se rompe o agrieta,
se forma un coágulo de sangre
alrededor de él en minutos,
y una arteria parcialmente cerrada
puede bloquearse completamente.
El flujo de sangre
al músculo cardiaco se corta
y las células privadas de oxígeno
comienzan a morir en cuestión de minutos.
Ese es un infarto de miocardio
o ataque al corazón.
Las cosas pueden deteriorarse rápidamente
en ausencia de tratamiento.
El músculo lesionado puede
no ser capaz de bombear la sangre tampoco
y su ritmo podría desfasarse.
En el peor caso, un ataque al corazón
puede causar la muerte súbita.
¿Cómo se sabe que alguien está
sufriendo un ataque al corazón?
El síntoma más común es dolor en el pecho
causada por el músculo
cardíaco sin oxígeno.
Los pacientes lo describen como
aplastamiento o parecido.
Se puede irradiar al brazo izquierdo,
a la mandíbula,
a la espalda,
o al abdomen.
Pero no siempre es tan repentino y
dramático como en las películas.
Algunas personas experimentan náuseas
o falta de aire.
Los síntomas pueden ser menos prominentes
en mujeres y ancianos.
En ellos, la debilidad y el cansancio
pueden ser la principal señal.
Y, sorprendentemente, en muchas personas,
especialmente aquellos con diabetes,
que afecta a los nervios
que transmiten el dolor,
un ataque al corazón
puede pasar silencioso.
Si crees que alguien podría estar
teniendo un ataque al corazón,
lo más importante
es responder rápidamente.
Si tienes acceso a servicios médicos
de emergencia, llama.
Son la forma más rápida
de llegar a un hospital.
Tomar aspirina,
que diluye la sangre,
y nitroglicerina,
que abre la arteria,
puede ayudar a evitar
que el ataque al corazón empeore.
En urgencias, los médicos
pueden diagnosticar un ataque al corazón.
Usan comúnmente un electrocardiograma
para medir la actividad
eléctrica del corazón
y un análisis de sangre para evaluar
el daño del músculo cardíaco.
Entonces el paciente es trasladado
a una sala de alta tecnología cardíaca
donde se realizan pruebas
para localizar las obstrucciones.
Los cardiólogos pueden volver
a abrir la arteria bloqueada
inflando con un globo en un
procedimiento llamado angioplastia.
Con frecuencia, también insertan
una férula de metal o polímero
que mantendrá la arteria abierta.
Bloqueos más extensos pueden requerir
cirugía de bypass de la arteria coronaria.
Usando un trozo de vena o arteria
de otra parte del cuerpo,
los cardiocirujanos pueden
redireccionar el flujo de sangre
alrededor de la obstrucción.
Estos procedimientos restablecer
la circulación en el músculo cardíaco,
restaurando la función del corazón.
El tratamiento ha mejorado,
pero la prevención es vital.
Tanto la genética y el estilo de vida
afectan su riesgo.
Y la buena noticia es que puedes
cambiar tu estilo de vida.
Ejercicio, una dieta saludable
y pérdida de peso
todo disminuye el riesgo
de ataques al corazón,
hayas tenido o no uno antes.
Los médicos recomiendan hacer ejercicio
varias veces a la semana,
haciendo tanto actividad aeróbica
como entrenamiento de fuerza.
Una dieta saludable para el corazón
es baja en azúcar y grasas saturadas,
ambas vinculadas a la enfermedad cardíaca.
Entonces, ¿qué debe comer?
Mucha fibra de las verduras,
pollo y pescado en lugar de carne roja,
granos integrales y frutos secos
como nueces y almendras
todos parecen ser beneficiosos.
Una buena dieta y ejercicio también pueden
mantener tu peso en rango saludable,
lo que reducirá también el riesgo
de ataque al corazón.
Por supuesto, los medicamentos también
pueden ayudar a prevenir los ataques.
Los médicos a menudo recetan
dosis bajas de aspirina, por ejemplo,
particularmente para pacientes que
ya han tenido un ataque al corazón
y para los que se sabe
que son de alto riesgo.
Y drogas que controlan
los factores de riesgo,
como la presión arterial alta,
el colesterol y la diabetes,
harán los ataques al corazón
menos probable, también.
Los ataques al corazón serán comunes,
pero no tienen por qué ser inevitables.
Una dieta saludable,
evitar el consumo de tabaco,
mantenerse en forma,
y disfrutar de mucho sueño y muchas risas
todo un largo camino para asegurar
que el músculo más importante del cuerpo
se mantenga latiendo.